avec marie aimée perron vice président
du conseil national des barreaux ancien
bâtonnier paris bonsoir marier mais
perraud merci avec nous une première
réaction à ce projet on le rappelle
censée restaurer la confiance des
français en la justice écoutez en tout
cas s'il y avait longtemps il y avait
même dix ans depuis la présence de
l'avocat lagarde en garde à vue que
notre ministère de la justice ne se
souciait pas du justiciable
et ça c'est indispensable de savoir que
d'encadrer les enquêtes préliminaires
dans des délais c'est indispensable
l'injustice ne peut plus être aussi
lente et c'est un premier pas il y
aurait beaucoup de pain à faire pour
restaurer la confiance des français dans
leur justice puisque un français sur
deux n'a pas confiance en sa justice
mais ça c'est une mesure qui est
importante que on puisse encadrer dans
le temps une enquête préliminaire vous
ne pouvez pas être victime avoir déposé
plainte et d'avoir aucune nouvelle ou
être poursuivis et ne pas savoir en fait
poursuivies avoir une enquête qui vous
concerne ne pas être informé c'est à
dire d'être informés obligatoirement
dans l'année c'est indispensable
qu'est-ce que ça va changer concrètement
ça et va provoquer une vraie
accélération du rythme judiciaire très
lent en tout cas on ne peut plus
accepter que des enquêtes préliminaires
dur pendant des années et des années et
des années
les français ne comprennent pas cela et
sur ce point nous sommes je suis
personnellement tout à fait d'accord
avec cette mesure qui va permettre
d'accélérer les enquêtes le problème
néanmoins ce sont les moyens financiers
de la justice et les moyens humains à
dire que nous avons besoin de magistrats
nous avons besoin de greffiers nous
avons besoin de davantage de moyens pour
la justice en france
alors on sait qu eric dupond moretti est
un ancien avocat aujourd'hui a quand
même quelques avocats qui ont grincé des
dents en prenant l'exemple de la gêner
gestion des cours criminel départemental
on rappelle la petite phrase quand même
un mois et demi avant son arrivée place
vendôme le garde des sceaux disait c'est
la mort de la cour d'assises
ceux qui préparent les projets de loi à
la chancellerie ce sont des magistrats
en déplacement donc c'est un projet fait
pareil pour les magistrats qu'est ce que
vous répondez 1 nous nous répondons
naturellement que nous sommes en total
désaccord avec cette généralisation des
cours dès qu'on découvre criminel
départemental
comment voulez vous qu'un une loi de
confiance pour la justice fait pour le
justiciable
on supprime les jurys pas les jurys
populaires en tout cas pour les pour les
débits pour les pour les déplore ce que
la peine encourue et entre 15 à 20 ans
c'est c'est pour rétablir la confiance
c'est certainement pas en supprimant les
jurys populaires sur des crimes qui sont
des viols
1 le plus souvent ça concerne des viols
ou les victimes ou les parties ont
besoin de ce temps les plaids les
personnes poursuivies ont besoin de se
tendre d'injustice et nous avons une
justice qui fonctionne très bien qui
sont les jurys populaires
nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec cette
généralisation
après une expérimentation qui n'en a pas
été une un puisque il ya eu très peu de
temps en fait pour expérimenter ces
chambres départementales séchant
criminel départemental est d'ailleurs le
rapport qui a été déposée à l'assemblée
n'est pas si convaincant que cela
pourquoi un tel revirement de la part du
garde des sceaux sont vous christian
saint-palais un président de
l'association des avocats pénalistes lui
porter un jugement sévère en avril
dupond moretti a choisi son intérêt
personnel dit-il
c'est ce genre de raison qui explique je
ne penserai peugeot je ne nierai pas en
ce sens aujourd'hui ce n'est pas eric
dupond moretti avocat
c'est eric dupond-moretti garde des
sceaux est vraiment sur ce point j'irai
que si le garde des sceaux se
contredisaient par rapport à ce qu'il
dit en tant que ministre cela me
gênerait qu'il se contredisent par
rapport à l'avocat ça nous concerne
personnellement un nez
en attendant nous nous ne sommes pas
d'accord avec cette suppression des
assises pour ces dossiers qui sont des
crimes
est ce que ce sont eux encore une fois
ça concerne plus particulièrement les
viols il a et la souveraine de
souveraineté du peuple je rappelle que
la justice est rendue au nom du peuple
et supprimer le peuple dans une loi de
confiance
pour la justice c'est une erreur en
annonçant ces tunnels
il ya un élément aussi de sa vraie forme
les audiences film est restitué est ce
que c'est une avancée pour vous oui bien
sûr bien sûr mais à condition d'encadrer
bien évidemment c'est à dire que cela va
permettre au français de davantage
connaître leur justice
mais il faut l'encadrer par rapport au
parti par rapport à la victime par
rapport à l'ensemble des parties
puisqu'il est question de faire
connaître aussi là la justice civile
c'est vrai que les français n'ont pas ne
connaissent pas le fonctionnement de la
justice
éviter cet entre soi mais il convient de
veiller d'une part à bien à obtenir les
autorisations
elles sont prévues mais je n'ai pas vu
de demande d'autorisation aux avocats et
aux magistrats concernés et puis tout
simplement ne pas le droit à l'oubli
c'est à dire de veiller au droit à
l'oubli donc oui mais à condition d'en
aimerait bien évidemment le projet de
loi prévoit aussi d'imposer un code de
déontologie pour à tous les
professionnels les avocats notaires
greffiers des tribunaux de commerce
est ce que c'est un effet d'annoncé cela
va vraiment changer les choses et
qu'est-ce que ça va changer
alors pour les avocats ça va nous et ça
ne changera rien puisque toutes les
façons nous avons notre code de
déontologie la discipline
vraiment ça ne modifiera en rien et je
rappelle que contrairement aux greffiers
contrairement aux huissiers au notaire
nous ne sommes pas des officiers
ministériels et que notre discipline et
notre déontologie par le conseil
national des barreaux
nous le nous l'assurons totalement nous
gérons plus de 6000 plainte à paris et
auxquelles nous répondons en permanence
là dessus je
nous sommes en discussion avec notre
ministre et je pense que le parlement va
avoir beaucoup à compléter ce projet de
loi va avoir d'avoir à améliorer ce
projet de loi dans le cadre de ses
travaux parlementaires
merci marie aimée peyrens vice président
du conseil national des barreaux ancien
bâtonnier de paris merci d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france